between the comic book panel and the
silver screen is an often overlooked
conceptual stage
that's an art form all its own that
visual design work is on display in
marvel's art book avengers infinity war
the art of the movie
while we wait and wonder about the 4th
avengers movie this new collection
provides an intriguing look
at the infinity war that might have been
the avengers are all over the emotional
spectrum when we catch up with them in
infinity war
but none are feeling lower than thor his
third solo movie ragnarok was a
cathartic experience for the character
it was a journey that required the god
of thunder to accept the loss and learn
to let go of his parents his palace
his eye and his beloved hammer meownia
sounds like he had a pretty special and
intimate relationship with this hammer
and that losing it was almost comparable
to
losing a loved one it's a nice way of
putting it
thor ended the movie growing as a person
ascending to the throne of asgard
to lead his people to a new home then
before the main title of infinity war
even appears
thanos wipes out half of the remaining
asgardians off-screen
from that point most of thor's story
involves forging the yak stormbreaker
to replace his long-lost hammer and get
some vengeance at some point though
marvel studios had a visual development
ryan miner ding imagined
thor wielding some sort of laser rifle
instead which he perhaps would have
gotten from his new friend rocket
raccoon
it's just as well that thor never ended
up wielding a gun in infinity war
that's really more of a scourge thing
one of infinity wars biggest surprises
was itray the giant dwarf played by
peter dinklage
the master of the forge of nidovalia e3
is the last survivor of his people
the rest having been wiped out by thanos
after they created his infinity gauntlet
with the help of thor and company he
re-fires the forge to make one a new
weapon in the hopes of thwarting the mad
titan
of particular help is grues who
sacrifices one of his own limbs
on the spur of the moment to make the
mighty axes handle according to concept
artist john straub
the original scene in the script just
said groot helps itray
giving me a lot of freedom to come up
with something interesting
and unique before settling on the final
version straub imagined a scene in which
groot formed a sort of exoskeleton
and acted as itri's arms anthony
francisco meanwhile
offered up a take on e3 that was
somewhat more aged and austere
than the disheveled survivor dinklage
became in the finished film the costume
chris evans wears in infinity war is a
darker colored variation on his captain
america uniform
with the white star conspicuously ripped
out it's a strong visual indicator that
while he's still the same selfless steve
rogers
we've always known he doesn't need the
americana trappings to show what his
ideals are
it's a great concept but it wasn't the
first concept the film's design team
considered
for inspiration the artists also looked
toward the comic book character us
agent who is typically known for his
black and red variation
of cups classic suits before settling on
the dark blue outfit we saw in infinity
war
marvel studios experimented with a
similar version of the look for steve
rogers
while most of the major players in
infinity war were already introduced in
previous films
the opening sequence brings a new team
of fresh faces to the fray
the children of thanos known in the
pages of marvel comics as the black
order
this phalanx of cretans act as heralds
to the mad titan
they announce his arrival and carry out
his will on each unfortunate world
that falls into his grasp since this
quartet had never been on screen before
infinity war's design team had more
freedom than usual
in their interpretation of the
characters in particular they
experimented with how expressive these
frightening gothic aliens should be
some of the early pastors at thanos's
children find them a little more
smiley than the stern figures they
became in the movie particularly these
takes on ebony more
and proxima midnight it's an unwritten
rule of the marvel cinematic universe
that tony stark must don at least one
new suit of iron man armor
every time he appears infinity war is no
exception
the suits have been growing increasingly
high tech ever since iron man 2 suitcase
armor but
infinity war's bleeding edge armor
represents a whole new frontier
using nano technology to create a
form-fitting hyper-responsive second
skin
that forms around stark at his command
it's enough to make the first iron man
movies technology looked downright
antiquated
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave
marvel's design team put no small amount
of thought into the construction of the
bleeding edge suit
as concept artist phil saunders
explained the suit is actually forming
all the anatomical hairs underneath
there's a sort of neurological layer and
a circulatory system layer that gets
formed
and then a layer of musculature it's
probably for the best that the movie
doesn't linger on this in-between phase
of the armor
it bears a disconcerting resemblance to
the off-putting flayed muscle look of
2011's green lantern
comic book history is so rich that even
costumes can have longer complex
legacies of their own
such as the case for the iron spider a
variation on spider-man's
identity occasionally adopted by peter
parker
the version of the suit deployed in
infinity war is basically a somewhat
shiny variant on the standard red and
blue motif but the development team also
tried a red and gold iteration
that struck much more closely to the
comics that inspired it
there was also a black version though
that one perhaps brought too much
resemblance to the symbiote suit seen in
spider-man 3.
wouldn't want to remind anyone of that
in his quest for the soul stone
thanos must travel to the planet vormir
and confront the guardian of the gem
that's hidden there in a twist that
shocked fans this guardian is revealed
to be none other than the red skull
last seen getting banished to another
dimension by the tesseract
at the end of captain america the first
avenger it goes without saying that the
skull has been subjected to some intense
cosmic punishment
since we last saw him and his decades of
isolation
fired up the imaginations of infinity
ward's character designs
concept artist ian joyner explained his
take as saying
the idea of really hollowing him out and
embracing the more horrific aspects of
his look was something i took a lot of
delight in exploring
the team's take on the new red skull run
the body horror gamut from a
thing that wouldn't be out of place in
the guillermo del toro movie
to a haunting vision of a cloaked wraith
that would be very much at home on an
iron maiden album cover
in the end the look was probably too
metal for the movie but as with all of
these prototype designs
it's neat to know what could have been
[Music]